two words you'll hear thrown a lot in
macroeconomic circles are monetary
policy monetary policy and fiscal policy
and fiscal policy and they're normally
talked about in the context of ways to
shift aggregate demand in one direction
or another and oftentimes to kind of
stimulate aggregate demand to shift it
to the right and what I want to do in
this video is focus on what these two
different tools are who are the actors
and how do they go about actually
shifting the aggregate demand curve so
monetary policy this is literally
deciding how much money to print so it's
literally printing money either deciding
to print more of it or deciding to print
less printing money
it's tends to be done in the United
States especially in most large
countries it's done by the central bank
it's done by the central bank which is
sometimes directly part of the
government sometimes it's quasi
independent in the u.s. it's a quasi the
US central bank which is the Federal
Reserve is quasi independent and in
future videos we'll talk more about the
governance structure of the federal of
the Federal Reserve
most of the major appointees are made by
the US government all of its excess
profits goes back to the US Treasury so
in that way it's part of the US
government but it's set up to be also
has some influence from private industry
the member banks have a have a stake in
what's going on it quoted often
coordinates amongst member banks so you
have your Federal Reserve as a central
bank in the United States it's quasi
independent but it's been given the
right to print money and I'll just draw
it here as physical dollars but most of
the money that it's going to print
actually is electronic money and what
the way this affects the aggregate
demand curve the Federal Reserve doesn't
just print money and go out and start
buying things with that money well it
does buy things but it doesn't go out
and buy goods and services what it does
with this is it essentially lends it out
so it's essentially buying debt so it
buys it buys debt and if buying debt
seems like a weird thing to say buying
debt is the same thing as lending money
lending money if I buy a Treasury bond
so if I'm buying debt
I'm buying a Treasury bond it means I'm
implicitly lending that money if I buy
the bond directly from the government
that means I'm lending that money to the
US government if I buy if I directly buy
a bond from a u.s. corporation I'm
essentially lending that money the
corporation they're going to give me
interest payments in the form of coupons
and then they're gonna pay back that
money at some future date so this is
essentially lending money and what this
does is it's increasing the supply of
money that's out there to be lent and so
if we think of the market for money so
listen now we're taking micro economic
terms for the market for money so the
market for money if this is the price of
money which is really just the interest
rate so interest interest rate as a
percentage and this right over here is
the supply of money supply of money and
I'll just draw so this might be our
supply curve that's supply and this is
the demand curve this is a demand curve
and let's say right over here let's say
and let's say this is short term money
and we won't focus on the different
durations and all of that but let's say
we're sitting right over here at a
clearing interest rate of 5% so it makes
sense this is right here this is our
demand our demand curve so all of the
people who will get more than 5% benefit
out of the money maybe they have an
investment where they could get 10% on
the money or 8% or 5.1% they're all
willing to borrow that money and then
invest it in whatever they want to do or
this might even be consumption people
who are say hey 5% that's worth it for
me to go out and buy that thing that
makes me whatever happy but from an
investment point of view it makes even
more sense if I'm gonna get an 8% return
on my money that's my benefit it makes
sense for me to borrow it at 5% it makes
sense all the way up to five point zero
zero zero one percent I'd actually
borrow it and so in the Federal Reserve
or any central bank prints money and it
buys debt it goes out into debt markets
and advise and usually buys the safest
kind of debt but that affects all of the
debt markets it goes out and buys debt
market they're essentially shifting the
supply curve of money to the right they
shifted the supply curve to the right
and so at any given interest rate you
could say that they are there is more
money and so the supply curve might look
something like that
and this is interesting because
assuming the demand has not shifted what
you now have is a different clearing
price a different equilibrium price for
the money maybe this is now at 3% this
is now at 3% now and you also have more
money being lent and borrowed so if this
was the old quantity of money that was
lent in borrowed let's say that this is
I'm just going to make up a number here
let's say that this is let's say this is
one hundred one hundred billion dollars
in some time period and now we're at a
hundred and twenty billion dollars one
hundred and twenty billion dollars so
now by essentially printing money buying
debt increasing the supply of money two
things happen interest rates went down
and so now you have all of these
characters out here who before they
weren't going to borrow money at 5%
because whatever they were their benefit
on that money was between 5% and 3%
maybe as 4% or 3.5% it didn't make sense
for them to borrow at 5% and invested or
get and only get a 4% return or a 3%
return but now that interest rates have
gone down now it does make sense for
them to borrow the money all the way
down to someone who has some type of
project or investment that has a 3%
return they also say hey I'm neutral
now you could borrow at 3% and then I
could invest but definitely the person
with three point one percent or three
point two percent if they have
investments that give them that much
they would definitely want to borrow and
we could assume that all this
incremental borrowings on this little
example that I did right over here all
this incremental 20 billion dollars of
borrowing it's going to be spent
people will borrow money not to just
like not to just sit but stuff it into
their into their mattresses they'll
borrow that money to go invest it in
some way to spend it and so what this
will do all of this will shift aggregate
demand to the right right here we're
talking in micro economic terms but then
if we think about aggregate supply and
demand so this is aggregate so this is
let me write aggregate aggregate right
over here this is price this is real GDP
this is our aggregate demand aggregate
aggregate demand and then our short-run
aggregate supply might look something
like this aggregate supply in the short
run and so if we're shifting aggregate
demand to the right where there's going
to be more demand for goods and services
these people are gonna borrow this much
spend it you're going to essentially
stimulate you are going to stimulate the
economy
so this shifts to the right you have a
situation where real GDP will go from
this state to this state right over here
so it was expansionary and obviously if
the Federal Reserve decides to print
less money or if they even decide to if
they essentially soak up the money
that's in the market by selling some of
the debt that they own so that they're
sucking dollars out of it then the
opposite effect would happen now fiscal
policy is essentially the government
directly going out there and demanding
goods and services from the economy so
this is essentially you have the
government you have the government it
has so two sources of revenue that it
can spend it has money from taxes it has
tax revenue and then it can go out and
borrow money and so it also has access
to debt markets and the when a
government borrows money they're
essentially issuing Treasury bills if
you talk about the US Treasury bills and
Treasury bonds if you were to buy those
from the US government you are
essentially lending money to the
government to finance their debt and so
they could take these two sources of
money and then if they decide to do if
they just have to spend more and let's
say that they're gonna hold taxes fixed
so they're not gonna take out any demand
from the economy they might ratchet up
debt and then ratchet up spending
ratchet up spending and then that this
government is directly going out there
and demanding more goods and services so
that could also shift the aggregate
demand curve to the right so these are
two different levers two different tools
that have been used in governments all
around the world to shift aggregate
demand one way or the other or to an
attempt to shift aggregate demand one
way or the other monetary policy is more
indirect printing money using that to
increase the supply of money that's out
there to be lent that lowers interest
rates and then because it lowers
interest rates more money there's more
willingness to borrow and invest that
money
fiscal policy you're directly going out
there and just buying more goods and
services by usually ratcheting
ratcheting up your debt or fiscal policy
could go the other way if you're trying
to restrain the economy you could lower
your debt lower your spending or you
could do some other combination